In diesem Kapitel stellen wir dir den Rahmen vor
um über Computerumgebungen nachzudenken
der sich sowohl auf deinen Laptop anwenden lässt
als auch auf Supercomputer skaliert
Am Ende dieses Kapitels
verstehst du das grundlegende Konzept von Computerressourcen
und wie sie miteinander zusammenhängen
Was sind Computerressourcen also genau?
Es sind die Komponenten, aus denen ein Computersystem besteht
Da wäre zunächst die CPU, also die zentrale Verarbeitungseinheit
die den Großteil der Befehle ausführt, dann der Arbeitsspeicher
oder RAM, der Daten vorübergehend hält
und Programmbefehle speichert
und dann haben wir GPUs, also Grafikprozessoren
die ursprünglich für die Grafikdarstellung entwickelt wurden
aber auch für allgemeine Berechnungsaufgaben eingesetzt werden können
die viel parallele Verarbeitung erfordern
wie wissenschaftliche Simulationen, Datenanalyse oder maschinelles Lernen
Diese Ressourcen arbeiten zusammen, um Programme auszuführen
und jede hat ihre eigene Maßeinheit
CPU-Ressourcen werden zum Beispiel in Kernen gemessen
und Taktfrequenz, während Speicher in Bytes gemessen wird
in Giga-, Mega- und Terabytes
Für jedes unserer Probleme
brauchen wir einen bestimmten Satz an Ressourcen
um sie ausführen zu können
Es ist entscheidend, die benötigten Ressourcen zu berücksichtigen
den Ort, an dem Programmkomponenten effizient ausgeführt werden
und die Bandbreite der verbindenden Infrastruktur
spielen eine wichtige Rolle
bei der Bestimmung der Gesamtleistung
Eine GPU kann zum Beispiel bestimmte Teile schnell berechnen
aber wenn das Laden des Programms in den GPU-Speicher
mehr Zeit kostet als die Berechnung selbst
könnte die CPU die schnellere Wahl sein
Lass uns nun über die Skalierung klassischer Ressourcen sprechen
Es gibt zwei Ansätze: vertikale Skalierung
und horizontale Skalierung. Vertikale Skalierung bedeutet, die Leistung
einer einzelnen Ressource zu erhöhen
etwa durch eine leistungsstärkere CPU oder mehr Arbeitsspeicher
innerhalb eines einzigen physischen Knotens
wobei ein Knoten eine Einheit eines Rechenclusters ist, die mehrere
Ressourcen bündelt. Horizontale Skalierung
bedeutet, weitere Ressourcen hinzuzufügen
wie mehrere CPUs oder GPUs
die gemeinsam auf einem oder mehreren Knoten arbeiten
Beide Ansätze haben ihre eigenen Vor-
und Nachteile, und die Wahl hängt vom konkreten Anwendungsfall
und den Anforderungen ab. Stellen wir nun einen neuen Ressourcentyp vor:
Quantenressourcen. Quantenressourcen verarbeiten Quanteninformation
mit einer Quantenverarbeitungseinheit, kurz QPU. Eine QPU
ist das gesamte System, das dafür verantwortlich ist
einen ausführbaren Quantenbefehlssatz
oder quantum circuit entgegenzunehmen und
eine genaue Antwort zurückzugeben. Das bedeutet
die QPU umfasst einen oder mehrere Quantenchips
zum Beispiel einen IBM Quantum Chip
sowie mehrere zusätzliche Komponenten
in einem Dilutionskryostaten
der den Quantenchip kühlt
wie Quantenverstärker, Steuerelektronik
und der klassische Computer, der benötigt wird
für Aufgaben wie das Speichern von Befehlen
und Wellenformen im Speicher, das Sammeln von Ergebnissen
und die zukünftige Fehlerkorrektur-Dekodierung
Quantenressourcen werden im Allgemeinen gemessen
nach ihrer Qualität, der Layer-Fidelity-Skala
der Anzahl der qubits
und der Geschwindigkeit, den circuit layer operations per
second oder CLOPS. Heute behandeln wir den Quantenchip
als Maßeinheit, ähnlich wie Ressourcenverwaltungssysteme
GPUs nicht nach der Anzahl der Kerne messen
sondern als gesamte Einheit. Was ist mit der Skalierung?
Wie bei klassischen Ressourcen lässt sich die Skalierung von Quantenressourcen
ebenfalls in vertikale
und horizontale Skalierung einteilen. Vertikale Skalierung
würde bedeuten, die Anzahl der qubits pro Chiplet
oder pro Chip zu erhöhen
Horizontale Skalierung würde bedeuten, Chips
mit Kopplern oder klassischen Verbindungen zu verknüpfen
Nachdem wir diese Begriffe geklärt haben
lass uns über Ressourcenverwaltung sprechen
Ressourcenverwaltung in der Computerinfrastruktur bezieht sich
auf den Prozess des Planens
Zuweisens und Kontrollierens des Einsatzes von Rechenressourcen
wie CPU, Arbeitsspeicher, Speicherplatz
und Netzwerkbandbreite, um einen effizienten
und effektiven Ressourceneinsatz sicherzustellen
Du kannst dir die Ressourcenverwaltung
wie ein mehrdimensionales Tetris vorstellen, bei dem die Blöcke
deine Job-Anforderungen sind
und jede Dimension eine Ressourceneinheit darstellt. Die Aufgabe
besteht darin, diese Job-Blöcke in den Würfel
all deiner verfügbaren Ressourcen zu packen. Ressourcenverwaltung
ist eine sehr komplexe Aufgabe, und verschiedene Rechenzentren setzen
unterschiedliche Strategien ein, um ihre Infrastruktur
auf die spezifischen Bedürfnisse ihrer Nutzer anzupassen
Um die Konzepte, die wir gerade gelernt haben, anzuwenden, werden wir
Slurm verwenden. Slurm ist eine Open-Source-Software
für die Ressourcenverwaltung
Zu Demonstrationszwecken habe ich
ein lokales Setup mit drei virtuellen Knoten
Informationen zu diesen Rechenknoten bekommen wir
durch Ausführen des Slurm-Steuerbefehls
Wir haben zwei Partitionen, also Knotengruppen:
normal und quantum. Die normale Partition besteht aus Knoten
die nur auf klassische Ressourcen zugreifen können
und die Quantum-Partition hat Zugriff auf Quantenressourcen
Lass uns zunächst das einfache
klassische Hello-World-Beispiel mit Slurm ausführen
Zuerst brauchen wir das Hello-World-Programm selbst.
Und hier ist unser Programm, das einfach "Hello
World" ausgibt.
Jetzt müssen wir dem Ressourcenmanager mitteilen
welche Ressourcen wir zur Ausführung dieses Programms benötigen
Wie besprochen bietet Slurm eine Möglichkeit, alle
Metadaten für einen Job zu definieren
in Form eines Shell-Skripts
mit einigen Slurm-spezifischen Anmerkungen
Diese Anmerkungen erlauben dir, die Ressourcenanforderungen
Scheduling-Parameter und mehr festzulegen.
Wir können unser Einreichungsskript überprüfen
und hier siehst du die Partitionsangabe
wie viele Knoten wir brauchen, wie viele Tasks pro Knoten wir
ausführen werden, wie viele CPUs pro Task wir verwenden
und welches Skript ausgeführt werden soll
und das ist unser Hello-World-Programm.
Um unseren Job zur Ausführung einzureichen, müssen wir nur
einen Befehl ausführen, nämlich slurm batch
und unser Skript als Argument übergeben
Wir können die Ausführungswarteschlange prüfen
und sehen, dass unser Hello-World-Programm läuft
auf der normalen Partition auf dem Knoten c1
Sobald der Job abgeschlossen ist, können wir die Ergebnisse prüfen
indem wir uns die Ausgabedatei ansehen.
Und das war's.
Wir möchten auch Quantenressourcen nutzen
also lass uns ein einfaches Hello-Qiskit-Programm erstellen.
Hier ist unser Qiskit-Programm, das alle
notwendigen Schritte der circuit-Erstellung
Optimierung, Ausführung und Nachverarbeitung enthält.
Und hier sind alle Programmierkonzepte, über die wir gesprochen haben:
quantum circuit, transpiler
und Qiskit-Primitives
Jetzt müssen wir wie zuvor ein Einreichungsskript erstellen
aber diesmal geben wir
die Anforderungen an Quantenressourcen an
Da wir die Ressourcen angegeben haben
und die Partition des Clusters
weiß das System, welche Quantenressourcen verfügbar sind
Die Qiskit-Primitives werden die
zugewiesenen Ressourcen nutzen, um die Quantenberechnungen auszuführen.
Jetzt müssen wir unser Programm ausführen.
Und sobald der Job fertig ist, können wir die Ergebnisse prüfen.
Und hier ist unser Erwartungswert.
Das war's zur Ressourcenverwaltung
Im nächsten Abschnitt werden wir über
Programmiermodelle sprechen